100 trillion dollars that's one followed
by 14 zeros
that is uh zimbabwe's biggest
denomination note from 2008. that year
saw zimbabwean hyperinflation hit one of
the highest levels in history with the
zim dollar essentially not even worth
the paper it was printed on
now inflation is down to 200 percent
still one of the highest rates in the
world zimbabwe's central bank is
introducing gold coins as a hedge it
says to reduce the need for u.s dollars
and curb those runaway prices so will
the bank's plan work
we'll get expert analysis on that in
just a moment but first dw news africa's
privileged
filed this report from harare
zimbabwe's new gold coin is named after
the country's world famous victoria
force
the reserve bank is billing it as a
magic bullet in the fight against the
country's inflation problems
the central bank's head says the aim is
to provide zimbabweans with a safe store
of value and reduce demand for u.s
dollars
many here prefer the greenback to the
weak local dollar which has lost more
than 70 percent of its value this year
we do respect the people of zimbabwe we
know what will be going through in terms
of
the fear factor of losing value and
therefore we are providing this gold
coin it's a genuine gold coin to show
that at least you will serve and you
invest there
but here in the capital harare
people are not convinced that the new
coin offers any solutions to the dire
economic hardships they are facing
let them use let them use their coins i
don't accept them i will i would rather
use those u.s dollars if i was in a more
financially stable position i it would
be something i would invest in but more
as as a collectible
not so much for trading
the new gold coin cost more than 1 800
us dollars at the launch
but buyers should be aware the central
bank says anyone purchasing the coin
must hold them for at least 180 days
so they are hardly legal tender that can
easily be converted to cash when
immediate need arises
economic analysts say the measure will
likely only benefit a few zimbabweans
with excess cash
gold coin is one of the schemes which
are going to make people richer those
who are rich and those who are poor
poorer and it will not be in a good
instrument to address the current
challenges happening in the economy
particularly the exchange respect and
inflation spikes
prices of basic commodities have
skyrocketed and have further eroding
confidence in any monetary and fiscal
policies that the government has tried
to introduce
with many people living hand to mouth
the government may have a hard time
convincing citizens to exchange their
greenbacks for gold discs
we can now speak to ten diabetes a
constitutional lawyer member of
parliament and former finance minister
of zimbabwe he joins us now from harare
welcome to the program mr bt now we're
talking about the gold coins uh in
zimbabwe which the imf has actually
called unusual no other country has used
gold coins in this way the government
says it this will reduce the demand for
u.s dollars do you think this will work
it won't work it won't work because the
gold coin is not a you know
it's not a currency uh so
it's not fungible you can't go into a
shop and buy goods
uh with it
it's the currency which is why the
minister of finance in this budget
statement today
described it as simply as a store of
value but if it's a store of value why
would anyone want to take us dollars to
buy full coins
so the whole thing doesn't work the gold
coin is basically a means of money
laundering the basically means of
stealing because it's going to be sold
in local currency it invaded the rates
at a rate that is below the market so
crooks are just going to
flood it using the local currency which
is cheap and then you get it outside so
it's going to be an instrument of money
laundering because we know that there
are billions of dollars in dubai in
southeast asia which are just going to
come
be dry cleaned in zimbabwe then it's be
shipped up as gold coins so it's an
instrument of arbitrage it's an
instrument of robbing the poor in
zimbabwe gold has had this reputation
for a long time as being fairly stable
as a
you know what something that people can
use to to store their fortunes you don't
think that this might help zimbabweans
especially considering the
wild inflation they've seen in the last
few decades
this is not 1500 or 1400 they do 1970
where the bullying was so important
as a means of storing value and nowadays
with currencies that are not perfect by
the point
so it's really pointless it's really
wasteful to actually use the the gold in
that
adequate
a manner that is why everyone sees this
strange including the imf because it is
unprecedented it is unprecedented so who
do you think is is is benefiting from
this you talk about stealing but who
exactly are these people
well with what cattails these mobile
economies run by cartels
and so these cartels have got
billions and trillions of dollars in
local currency
which they have to convert
into something that is valuable
so they are the ones that have put
pressure on the reserve bank to meet
this gold so that they can
convert their useless mapping dollars
into something with value and at a low
premium
so they're having their cake and eating
it and this is exactly what is happening
that's ten diabetes a constitutional
lawyer member of parliament and former
finance minister of zimbabwe thank you
for speaking to us
and to analyze this further i'm joined
by chennai muthambasare she is a
zimbabwean development economist based
in the uk and she joins us now from near
manchester welcome to dw news africa
chennai uh we've just seen from a report
from our correspondent some skepticism
from average zimbabweans
over these gold coins are their concerns
justified
thank you for having me on your show
absolutely their concerns are justified
um like we said when the announcement
was first made about these gold coins
that indeed the devil will be in the
detail of how
the central bank intends on
operationalizing these and now that we
are here
we have a lot of concerns surrounding
the way in which they are minted
surrounding the framework that goes um
in terms of supporting the gold coins
and how they can be accessed and how
they can be bought there are so many
discrepancies that actually suggest that
as opposed to being a new strategy we
are just seeing the failed interchange
auction rebranded and re-staged as gold
coins
so who exactly stands to benefit from
this
this new this introduction
we are again seeing um those that have
access to rtgs um to the value of 800
5000 and upwards which are generally in
zimbabwe the corporate elite
the um average salary for a teacher is
around 20 000 rtgs a month so that
they've able to save to afford uh one
gold coin is going to take them a really
really long time so generally similar to
what we've seen with the interchange
auction is those that are politically
connected the corporate elites that do
have access to uh north of 805 000 rtgs
but unfortunately the way in which they
will benefit will only seek to benefit
the individuals in the way that they
will take advantage of potential
arbitrage dealing by the fact that they
are being pegged at a discounted rtgs
rate
versus the us dollar so it's possible to
actually buy using your rtgs and sell
back
at u.s dollar value to even the banks
and be able to make as much as 115
percent from one gold coin just from
taking advantage of the arbitrage um
foreign currency dealing because the
gold coins are being packed at the inter
exchange auction rate which is a
discounted rate and it's only accessible
by those that hold that amount of rtds
and generally those will be the uh
corporate elites
all right chennai muthamba
zimbabwean development economist based
in the uk thanks for speaking to us
thank you
[Music]
living conditions in ghana are at their
worst in 18 years with inflation now
nudging 30 percent and their currency
the cd losing value ghana is also headed
for an imf bailout the government blames
the situation on the covet 19 pandemic
and russia's invasion of ukraine
traders and ordinary citizens are
feeling the brunt isaac kalezi sent us
this report from ghana's capital accra
for two decades now john kwame appear
has made a steady living from his
electrical goods shop
for him and his employees that's meant a
good income from the source floor
but now he fears for his livelihood
appiah says ghana's economic crisis is
hitting his customers hard
and he is suffering on the supply side
prices
of products and goods have gone very
very high and that is affecting trades
terribly
we are all losing our capital as i tell
you now because things are not
good at all
it comes to uh purchasing power of the
average gun it has been reduced
drastically now people cannot even come
to town to come to buy what they want to
buy
ghanaians haven't seen inflation this
high
since appear set up his shop 20 years
ago runaway prizes are now in a way at
people's buying power wherever they look
costs for food and other essentials are
surging
for prices going through the roof for
ordinary people it's a daily struggle
just to get by there's inflation on
everything
food commodities four prices so as an
average ghanaian i received a salary of
600 cities so with 600 cities my
transports now it's like i pay twice of
what i used to pay
with an amount of 10 cities i can't get
a decent meal
for me personally i'm finding it very
difficult yeah to
have a family i have a wife i have
children and then i have to also get up
for their school fees and all these are
coming with
more
interest you understand saving and i had
a bank also it's another good thing the
interest rate now is hard
ghana's economic fundamentals are dire
public finances are unsustainable
the country's debt to gdp ratio is
around 85 percent
the tax tick is low despite a new levy
on electronic transactions
protest and pay disputes forced the
government to suddenly make a u-10 and
head to the imf to ask for a bailout
here is the country's vice president a
former central banker with the
challenges in
accessing the international capital
market balance of payment support
was needed
to bridge this financing gap
stabilize the economy and create the
space to implement structural reforms
and restore debt sustainability and this
is really the reason why ghana had to go
to the island
economists agree that a crisis could
have been avoided if the government had
kept tighter controls on spending
the challenge is we've got issues with
excessive
you know debt borrowing
and we lack discipline
in our physical conduct
and so
the government
have reached a level that the debt
levels are extremely unsustainable
now guyanese politicians want to import
help from the imf but reports say that
won't be in place till early 2023
meanwhile john kwamiyapia can only hope
that his customers will keep coming and
that his business will keep running
oh that's the example of ghana but we
want to widen this out so let's bring in
kevin o'rama the african development
bank's acting chief economist and vice
president welcome to dw news africa um
you're speaking to us from washington
where you've been presenting the 2022
african economic outlook at the imf and
this comes at a time when a lot of
african countries are really struggling
with
the economic crisis crises uh you know
huge debt um what can these african
countries do to make sure they don't
become
for example the next sri lanka
the
challenges that are you know in african
countries just like around the world
because of several
overlapping global challenges that we
have
has several solutions that can be
domestic
in terms of what african countries can
do but also there are things that the
global community needs to do in order to
support africa to recover from these
shocks including the shocks of that
overhang as you have mentioned so one of
the key things that needs to be done is
for african countries to improve their
capacity in mobilizing resources
revenues internally
improving the quality of taxation and
also non-tax revenues that comes into
the country
into the countries because that will
help to improve and increase the
capacity of the countries to fund
development and borrow less
we've just seen for example in ghana
where they've been even protests people
uh the average person uh getting getting
hit by this several other countries on
the continent
from your point of view just how bad are
the continent's poorest countries faring
now the continence poorest
countries in africa are really suffering
from several challenges let me talk
about one which was a main theme of the
aeo
the impacts of
climate change you know we have all been
talking about the impacts of covet 19
which is huge it has pushed over 30
million people annually into
abject poverty in africa it has caused a
lot of jobs to be lost a lot of
employment
unemployment and so on but also we have
this challenge that has been persistent
which is the impacts of climate change
that is really creating major
challenges for governments around the
world and especially in africa
losing billions of dollars in
infrastructure that are destroyed by
climate impacts losing loss of lives and
livelihoods and so on so african
governments really have a lot of
challenges that need a lot of financing
support from the developed developed
world in order to support africa to be
able to recover from the many shocks
which were not caused by these countries
kevin urama the africa development
bank's acting chief economist and vice
president many thanks for speaking to us
[Music]
more than 80 percent of kenyans say they
are suffering under the cost of living
crisis and official figures make clear
that high inflation is worst affecting
the poorest kenyans will get to vote on
their leaders soon with the hope of
improving living conditions dw news
africa's correspondent felix moringa
sent us this report from the kenyan
capital nairobi
kibera islam is kenya's biggest informal
settlement and in her kiosk josephine
ogota is preparing traditional greens
for one of her customers the cost of
basic commodities have doubled even
tripled but it's kenya's temple food
maze that's worrying her the most
you can take tea without sugar and still
survive
you can make greens without cooking oil
but there is no substitute for
ugali the cost of maize flour has risen
drastically
that's hurting everyone the most
food prices have been going up across
the continent economist dr xn iraqi says
several factors have contributed to the
rise supply constraints
under investment in agriculture
were in ukraine they have what
participated in making inflation go up
and what it means by ordinary kenyans
that people are suffering they cannot be
able to get enough food they cannot
travel where they want they cannot pay
fees so the people most affected by
inflation are the people at the lower
assurance of their society
now just ahead of the elections kenya's
president uhuru kenyatta has intervened
to cut the price of maizefla by half
maze flowers shall retail across the
entire territory of the republic of
kenya
at the price of kenya shillings 100
down from kenya shillings 205
for a 2kg packet
until otherwise directed
many kenyans seem unconcerned that the
timing of the mesha could be political
they just want cheaper food
the important thing to note is whether
it's a political move or not a political
move
kenyans want meze fla from wherever it
will come from
this happens every election time this
time around we're telling them they
should not increase the maize flower
prices after the elections
they should also reduce the cost of
other commodities like sugar and rice
since you can't eat ugali every single
day
josephine is one among the many kenyans
who continue to struggle with the rise
in the prices of the basic food
commodities the two leading presidential
candidates have promised to deal with
the food prizes once they occupy office
but she remains doubtful
those are empty promises they're just
looking to be elected when they get to
office they won't change anything
empty promises won't feed empty stomachs
at home josefin prepares food for her
family not knowing if she'll have
another meal herself today
and we'll have a special edition of dw
news africa from our studio in nairobi
covering the leading candidates and all
the issues in kenya's upcoming elections
in next week's show
[Music]
these school children in south africa
finally have water again after a
borehole was drilled in their school
yard
four years ago cape town was facing the
threat of day zero the day when water
was expected to run out that never came
to pass because people saved water and
the rains came now another town has the
same problem quebec formerly port
elizabeth in eastern cape has
experienced seven years of drought our
correspondent adrian kriesch sent us
this report
not a drop in the tap in sipokasi
tembani's house for seven months now the
supply has run dry
the arrival of the water truck brings
some relief but tembani knows that it
also spells hard work
she has to carry the water all the way
home for herself and her four
grandchildren
we are getting sick because of carrying
this water every day my joints hurt i
have body pains i have to take
painkillers to sleep or go to the clinic
especially for us elderly people the
situation is painful
that is that
this dam should provide water for her
home but it's almost empty it's only
filled to less than 15 percent of its
capacity only four percent is usable
water rainfall is getting more and more
sporadic and it isn't as heavy as it
used to be for seven years the area here
has been in the grip of a historic
drought but while climate change
certainly plays a role mismanagement
decaying infrastructure and a lack of
maintenance certainly do too it is
estimated that about one third of the
water supply are lost due to leaking
pipes
the scale of the problem is clear to see
all over town
residents report about 200 leaks every
day the city has employed additional
staff for repair works and new wells are
being drilled groundwater is supposed to
help pluck the gap that the missing
rainwater has left the head of water
distribution for the municipality says
but why didn't all this happen much
earlier
the quite a number of reasons some of
them is financial arrangements
obviously from a municipality point of
view we have got competing priorities
from a service delivery perspective and
you know some of these
resources financial resources were
directed to other projects a lot of
people we talked to actually blame the
municipality for the current situation
at this point in time my focus is to be
able to deliver the metro and push the
day zero and all our efforts you know
are going towards that
day zero that's the day when all water
reserves will be used up the worst case
scenario to avoid it each resident is
supposed to use no more than 50 liters
of water per day with a municipality
threatening to impose strict controls
in the poor neighborhood of sipukasi
tembani people feel they have been given
empty promises for months even the water
truck that is a lifeline for so many
isn't organized by the municipality it
comes from an aid organization called
gift of the givers
i blame the municipality but also the
politicians when it is time to campaign
for votes you find a lot of them here
asking for votes but when the time comes
to deliver services to the people they
are nowhere to be found when we need
water they are nowhere to be found
has given up hope in politics her only
remaining hope that rain may fall soon
so she will get a break from the hard
work of fetching water